Okay. What's your answer?
>> My answer is no.
>> No, I'm sorry, that's wrong. No, no, I think that, well, if
it's, if it's right, then we need to provide a sequence that proves it.
>> Okay.
>> So what are you thinking?
>> Well, I was thinking actually something very similar to what we just saw.
>> Okay.
>> Where so tit for tat, what they're going to do is they're
going to do cooperate, cooperate, cooperate, cooperate,
right? That's what they normally want to do.
>> Exactly.
>> So what would happen if at one
point, one of them defected?
>> Okay, just for simplicity let's make it the very first point.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, tit for tat number one defects,
and tit for tat number two also defects.
>> At the very first time? No, it
cooperates, because it's done at the same time.
>> Well, I mean so we're, we can feed
it anything we want. So we could tell tit for
tat two to cooperate. So it's sort of like we've
taken over its brain for a brief amount of time.
>> Right. So I'm not yet convinced it's going to matter
for this, but the thing is that from that point
on, tit for tat two is going to want to, for
the next step tit for tat two is going to want to defect.
>> That's right.
>> And, tit for tat one would want to cooperate.
>> Uh-huh.
>> And that's sort of. Sucks.
>> [LAUGH]
>> For tit-for-tat two, right?
>> So, I don't know, so maybe we should try
to think through. What is the expected reward, for tit-for-tat
two, to actually do this defect at this time?
>> Or wait, no. So, so, sorry to,
to stick with the tit-for-tat machine at this time.
>> Well, what's going to happen at
that point is, it's going to keep alternating.
>> That's exactly right. So it's going to get the, the rewards corresponding
to D versus C, C versus D, D versus C, C versus D.
>> Over and over again.
>> Yeah. So let's thi, let's think about it
in the average reward case. So, in the D versus
C, if it does D when the other machine does C, then it gets zero.
>> Mm-hm.
>> If it does C when the other one does D it gets minus nine.
>> And then this alternates. So if we look at the average award,
which is basically what you get when the discount factor's very, very high.
>> Mm-hm.
>> It's scoring negative 4.5.
>> Right.
>> Is there any way, that it could behave against tit for
tat, starting from this point that would do better than negative 4.5.
>> Just go ahead and cooperate.
>> Just cooperate forever?
>> Well cooperate the next time and then keep doing tit for
tat from that point on. It'll work out to be cooperate forever.
>> On average. That's right. What will get is a minus, minus
one. So not being tit for tat at that point but instead,
instead turning always to cooperate would actually get it better. So the
idea that is should defect at this point, is an implausible threat.
>> Exactly.
>> So this is not
sub-game perfect. So yes, you nailed it.
>> Yeah!
>> Does that make sense?
>> It did make sense.
>> Good, alright. So that leaves open the question of, is
there a way, to be sub game perfect in Prisoner's dilemma?
>> Can I ask you a question?
>> Sure.
>> Before you answer that. So, I had sort
of convinced myself that it didn't matter whether tit for
tat number two started out with C or started out
with D. I'm trying to decide whether that's actually true.
>> 'Kay, that's a
good question. So what will happen, at this from
this point on if we now continue. We, you
know, we took over the brains for tit for
tat, and we forced them to play defect against defect.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And now we release that, and we let them do what, whatever it is
that they're going to do. And what is
th, what are they going to do? Is [CROSSTALK]
>> They would defect forever [CROSSTALK]
>> Defect forever.
>> Yeah.
>> And is there anything that tit-for-tat two machine,
could do to get a better score than that?
>> Cooperate.
>> Yeah, so it could. Cooperating with tit for
tat will bring it back into mutual cooperation.
>> Hm.
>> It will actually get a better score.
>> Yeah.
>> So, in one case, it would average to minus one and the other one, it
would, it would average to minus three and
minus one is better, so, you're right. Good point.
>> Okay.
>> So what matters is that we get we get them defecting.
>> Right. Okay, so that makes sense. So, I, I was right that
it didn't matter, although you do get
slightly different answers, or slightly different averages.
>> That's right.
But in both cases, there's a way of getting a higher average.
>> Right. Okay, cool, that's what I thought. I thought it was
something like that. So now, let's go back to what you wanted
to do. So, are we going to be able to figure out how
to do Prisoner's dilemma in a way that is sub game perfect?
>> Well, how about I propose a machine, and we'll see what it does?
>> Okay.